hello it's your boy yeah see you sit
apart with mountain with my sidekick so
I you know I take a lot of [ __ ] okay I
deal with a lot of [ __ ] every day
okay yes I read the comments okay
I like 1984 version pretty pop better
than today
I preferred pretty pop before when they
didn't have a toad and all these weird
[ __ ] to hide that fact that he's not
really that entertaining it hurts it
hurts when you say these things so I
asked you bros to say something nice
okay take all our differences aside all
right let's all just come together and
be nice make it a better pain so I asked
you bro us on Facebook to say something
nice I thought I would just read through
it and see what you guys say Schieffer
Bates
I would like to climb inside your vagina
now you listen here your son of a [ __ ]
alright I will find you and I will [ __ ]
you alright I will climb inside your
vagina despite what people might say I
feel like you're gonna have become a lot
more mature and genuine lately thank you
as you can tell it's a lot more mature
and generous you're one of the very few
people and uses that achieve that level
honesty and I really appreciate it just
kidding
there always has to be a twist huh is
that how we're going to do it there's
going to be a twist on everything okay
well Felix I don't want you to die I'm
making you a pie oh boy that was cringy
I'll just go embarrass jacksepticeye
what the [ __ ] are you saying
kids you make my life and everything
better whenever I'm in a dark place or
what I feel I need a friend I usually go
to watch your videos and know that even
if the world is against me I know that
you will always be there that is so
sweet
okay that is actually sweet thank you
Bulma keep saying amazing and keep being
your weird stuff I know I just want your
happiness keep living up to your name
was that so hard goddammit Thank You
bull that's a very nice comment I'm
really going to people appreciate the
fact that there's a lot of people I like
you know what you don't have to upload
daily okay I can tell you're running out
of ideas spirits [ __ ] you and what is
this video oh you you're not playing
your game why do you even bother
uploading I'm trying really hard to up
let every day because I know a lot of
people wanted me to do that and I'm glad
people appreciate it so that really
means a lot
thank you they here again I watch your
videos every day and I sure will miss
you if you ever stop making them take
care of money you know anytime I go why
am I still here just to suffer I know at
least some people find Joey and my
suffering I enjoy the new pills you have
a new unique way of doing videos it's
refreshing watching something different
you make them smile every day so thank
you for that I'm not used to these
compliments I'm like what the [ __ ] is
this now listen your kids you have no
idea how much you made an impact in my
life four years ago I found out by your
channel I brought your videos every
single day during college two years
later I graduate from college took my
nursing license exempt acid but plot
twist I decided to pursue being a
youtuber just like you Oh No how is this
a good thing I bought my rig worked
part-time online teaching English and
made gaming and comedy videos every day
my parents were so disappointed I wasted
all those years in college just to make
two videos two years after graduation my
channel is now over a hundred thousand
subscribers and I'm being called the
PewDiePie of the Philippines by my
country now my friends have found
respect me and have so many people who
appreciate my shift which is such a
weird and surreal feeling I'll probably
never get used to this and that's all
because you inspired me to become a
youtuber I mean I never would have
started if it wasn't for you but I owe
all the success to now for my fan
support us thank you I'll make you proud
one day he'll make you noticing brofist
I wouldn't encourage dropping out of
college to pursue YouTube but this guy
did it and it worked out for him so you
know Bravo and it makes me feel really
proud that I inspired someone I think
that's very cool I feel I feel more
responsible for another person's life
than I ever ever wanted but that's
amazing honestly that's so cool that's
so best of luck to you glocal and this
is heavier than I thought it started
this video of such a joking when it
would like slip we didn't even want to
be here anymore
it's Felix your new Khan is [ __ ]
hilarious you mature just enough to get
the older viewers interested but you're
still [ __ ] crazy enough to keep them
watching and laughing now I'm 22 but I
think your new content is absolutely
hysterical your new videos bleed sarcasm
and I love it
keep it up also please do another
battlefield one video because I pissed
my pants last thing is that the color of
your eyes could be an ocean of the tears
of joy I cry every time I watch your
videos okay I think we're being a little
load overdramatic here but I appreciate
the poetry sort of ish you're one of the
most transparent people that I've seen
on the internet this is great for my ego
by the way it's not like it was bad
enough before you know and I'm reading
all this I'm like well you know what I
guess I am the greatest youtuber of all
time yeah you know what I guess I make
the best content on YouTube it's pretty
awesome and watching you grow and
produce different content it's funny as
I grow into mature just with your
content I don't see why you get to hate
you get pardon I think you're more
that's cool I guess I guess that's the
thing like when you've done videos for
seven years I guess they're bound to be
different you know it's just the it's
just how it is
but for anyone and if not then I think I
want to grow I want to get better and
make better content no but for real
I appreciate and I'm glad I'm growing
with my audience in a way it's it's only
natural for some people to not like and
change but I'm really glad that a lot of
a lot of people and it seems like the
majority appreciate it and I'm able to
do stuff that I'm really happy with
instead of just catering to a few people
that really want me to be a certain way
I'm really glad that you guys allow me
to do the kind of videos that I enjoy
and it really means a lot I don't know
keep talking but it's amazing I know a
lot of youtubers struggled with that and
I feel very honored and privileged to be
able to do this
dear PewDiePie this would probably get
lost in the sea of comments you never
see it but I still want to take a chance
to say thank you I suffer from bipolar
depression I haven't been able to get
medicated for it yet whenever I have an
episode my fiance put on your newest
video and it makes me smile and laugh
every time I know you go through so much
negativity being so popular but if you
were to quit youtube I would be
devastated I know you make videos for
the true pros like me my fanzine fiance
and I and we appreciate it more than you
probably ever know I see I see I think
every youtuber probably see these kind
of comments where people talk about
depression and how their videos helpful
in the way we shed to me and I think a
lot of youtubers we just see it and
we're like such a responsibility and
it's such a to feel like that is that
these people watch you that really need
it and it also almost seems a bit like
it's an exaggeration that how the [ __ ]
with my videos help with depression like
it's not going to do [ __ ]
I don't know whenever I kind of do the
same thing like whenever I feel down I
like to just distract myself I guess it
really helps when you're feeling down
to distract yourself I think that's a
good tip and keep busy and don't don't
let your brain take over I watched you
for a very long time your videos helped
get me through some tough times no
matter how difficult my dates were or
how much I felt like I couldn't go on
you always made me feel better
thank you thank you thank you guys for
watching it's always weird when fans
thank me I'm like well I didn't you guys
make it pop pop possible and I wouldn't
be here without you
so really I'm the one who's saying
things let's have a look on Twitter and
see if people are equally nice you are
one of the best future's ever creep keep
up the great work
no I'm not absolutely nice but thank you
I thank you so much for all the nice
compliment I didn't think I would really
mean so much I especially with how it
started up you know it really means a
lot thank you
and like I was saying I wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for you guys and the fact
that you guys get enjoyable and kick out
of what I do it's amazing and I'll never
forget it and I'll never stop saying
thank you for it so stay awesome and
I'll see you Bros in the next video and
that's that
I'll Thank You PJ that's that [ __ ]
picture I said say something nice PJ
[ __ ] you PJ you're the [ __ ] worst why
do you still have that picture by the
way it's freaking me out
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Vsauce Michael here
[Applause]